اعلن الجيش اللبناني اليوم تحريره
المواطنه السعودي مشاري المطيري الذي تعرض
للاختطاف ليله السبت الماضي وتوقيف مختطف
فيه قال الجيش اللبناني في بيان ان دوريه
من مديريه المخابرات تمكنت من تحرير
المواطن السعودي المخطوف بعد عمليه وصفها
بالنوعيه على الحدود اللبنانيه السوريه
وفي ردود الفعل اكد رئيس حكومه تصريف
الاعمال اللبنانيه نجيب ميقاتي حرصه لبنان
على منع استخدام اراضيه منطلقا لاي عمل
يهدد امن الدول العربيه وسلامتها
من بيروت ينضمرون مراسل الجزيره ايهاب
العقده يعني
الاختطاف كان غريبا
والتحرير كان سريعا ما الملابسات كيف تمت
من الذي قام بالاختطاف من الذي قام
بالتحرير
طبعا اسئله كثيره تنتظر بعض الاجابات عنها
من الاجهزه الامنيه التي تتابع عمليه
التحقيق وايضا المداهمات لتتبع بقيه
العصابه التي قامت بعمليه خطف المواطن
السعودي عمليه تحرير هذا المواطن جرت في
ساعات الصباح الاولى جرى رصد ومتابعه
العصابه
وتحديد المكان الذي كانت تختبئ فيه
وتتستر فيه على المخطوف السعودي فقامت قوه
من استخبارات الجيش بمعمليه المداهمه
وحررت المخطوفه السعودي والقت القبض على
عدد من الخاطفين لكن العمليه الامنيه وفقا
لمصادر امنيه مستمره لتتبع بقيه افراد
العصابه التحقيقات ايضا مع المحرر السعودي
تجري في من قبل الاستخبارات الجيش لتحديد
ملابسات واخذ معلومات
الداخليه اللبنانيه التي كان اعلن وزير
الداخليه بسام الملوي الليله الماضيه ان
لبنان والسلطات ستضرب بيد من حديد وستقوم
بملاحقه وانزال اقصى العقاب بمن قاموا
بعمليه الخطف للمواطن السعودي
رئيس الوزراء اللبناني نوهه بالاجراءات
التي قام بها الجيش اللبناني تحرير
المخطوف واعتبر ان ذلك يساهم في تعزيز
مسار الامن في لبنان وهو كان اشار الى ان
ذلك لن يمنع من تحديد المسؤوليات في هذه
عمليه الخطف واعتبر ان ما يجري ياتي في
اطار
العمليات الامنيه المستمره لتثبيت
الاستقرار والامن في لبنان وهو ما تحاول
الحكومه التثبيت التاكيد عليه خلال مسار
زمني منذ الشهور سده الرئاسه اللبنانيه
واعتبار الحكومه اللبنانيه مستقيله